watch this as Byron just lays out the
nonsensical case against Trump look at
Wolf's face the whole time it's pretty
Priceless they don't even cite the
actual felony charge they're saying it
has something to do with the 2016
elections he was trying to subvert the
elections I mean it's clear that Alvin
Bragg had was on a mission to indict
Donald Trump and so that's how we got to
where we are but you say 34 felonies but
what are we actually talking about for
the prosecutors argue in this indictment
that Trump's goal was to hide damaging
information that's a direct quote
damaging information from American
voters just ahead of the 2016 election
Hillary Clinton spents a million dollars
on a fake dossier citing that he was a
Russian plant we all know that to be
true so it's okay to spend a million
dollars of campaign cash to create a
phony dossier to secrete through the
media to tilt the 2020 to 2016 election